I think the U.S government is full of
criminals and corrupt Psychopaths and
then you have people like Julian Assange
who are like I'm going to expose evil
people right technically he's a criminal
like he got classified information and
revealed no that was not a criminal at
all
it is actually he's protected by the
First Amendment and he's not even
American citizer to receive and disperse
classified information you're allowed to
do that the New York Times does it every
journalist yeah there's whistleblower
laws that protect individuals that come
forward and say hey there was some
wrongdoing in our government many people
tried to go through the official Avenues
and and they of course were told to shut
up you just can't have stolen the
documents himself but if they're
provided to him he has the ability again
like he said that's what journalism they
do that all the time but like even if he
knows they're stolen yes yes so like I
can't commit the crime but if someone
else does it for me then I'm on the
clear if I didn't adore you if they
didn't direct them to